fakes now dribbles foul line jumper shot  it's good  middleton nails another [ __ ] up  two this game is not that complicated  sometimes you  make it too complicated  now booker with tucker on him throws it  up for ayton  shot blocked by a gunner what a block  from giannis  and a good job by middleton settle down  get right back into that action  this building is shaking  sensational block shot this is one of  the great recovery plays  you'll ever see the log booker  to eight we've seen it many times and  that reaction  and block is special multiple effort  on the play stops the penetration of  booker doesn't give up  turns elevates blocks the layup attempt  that's big time  what a series here in this 2021 nba  finals here in game four the bucks win  it 109 to 103.